yeah so today I'm gonna talk about a
causal inference and scenario generation
within uh just the takeaway uh just the
takeaway is the motor company of the
Dutch tires you recognize it with the
orange house
and as you already said I'm the lead
data scientist in the central data
science team and the central data
science team serves as a kind of central
Hub of Excellence for from which we do
our data science projects
yeah so to give a little bit of a
background here I'm gonna talk about
causal inference and synthetic data
generation and scenario generation and
these are two different parts of data
science and causal inference and it was
also discussed a lot during today is
mainly
interested in treatment effects you want
to isolate the treatment in order to
make a causal statement about that
with scenario generation we mostly using
predictive models we drop the
requirement of causality and we're just
interested in generating likely
scenarios even though these things are
hugely different they all serve the same
purpose of making actionable insights
for us so in the end I believe these
topics also share the same goal for us
so let me first let me first talk a
little bit about experimentation within
just the takeaway so suppose we want to
know the causal effect of having free
lunch delivery
um yeah free lunch delivery
first thing we need to remember when in
Jersey takeaway is that not every
restaurant on our platform is the same
we have Marketplace Marketplace
restaurants do their own delivery we
have Logistics on our platform they
redo delivery for their for those
restaurants
depending on the location for which you
live in a city you can either see
Marketplace or logistic or both in the
in the app there's no difference for you
as a consumer
we can decide the price for those
logistic restaurants for delivery
Marketplace we have no control over that
the restaurants can decide for
themselves
so if we want to do an experiment with
free delivery remember we can only
affect the delivery price of some of the
restaurants not all
so we have to be very careful in our
experimentations so that's one part of
the problem
the other part is the the main tool for
statisticians to do causal inference are
the randomized controlled experiments
can we really do those huh well if you
think about it the the the the the the
best experiment the optimal experiment
that we want to run is a completely
randomized a b experiment where within
the city uh everybody gets either free
lunch uh or a delivery or not right
well if I have an app open and it says
free delivery and where you have an app
open which doesn't say it and we're
sitting in the same room well obviously
I'm gonna order it through my uh app
because I have the free delivery even
worse it could be that on the website I
have free delivery in an app uh I don't
and so there you can see there's a
spillover effect here this is not good
so this is a violation of the stable
unit treatment value assumption and
there's obviously also some legal and
ethical objections that you uh that are
here
so what do we do
we now enter a little bit in the realm
of Quasi experimentation with quasi
experimentation
um we instead of
uh having a control and a variant we're
gonna estimate the counter factual and
it's counter factual is basically a
situation what would have happened if
um the treatment was not applied so we
have a city like eindhover it has a free
delivery in our case during lunch time
what would have happened to eindhover if
there was no free deliveries in terms of
for example order volume
and what we have to remember if we're
randomizing uh yeah we're randomizing
now across cities
uh so not within the city but
randomizing over cities
is
um yeah there's a huge differences
between these cities iinto is very
different than Utrecht it's very
different than Amsterdam obviously and
not only are there differences among
cities there's also differences along
time and so we cannot just compare
before and after in December people are
ordering more out so we have to remember
their strength changes so there's
individual changes and time changes so
how are we now going to estimate this
counterfactual that is a challenge
so this is very classical approach and I
think if you come from an econometrics
background you've heard of this a
difference in difference approach but I
still think it's worthwhile to go over
that over this and kind of get a few of
the the approach we can take here
so with the difference in difference
approach so this is one of the ways in
which we can estimate this
counterfection a what-if situation
look at the picture on the right we have
a red line and a green line and suppose
these are two cities we have a before on
the left and an after on the right and
we see there's individual differences
The Intercept of these graphs are
different and there's a change over time
let's say left is November right is
December more orders over time
so if we assume that
both these cities have a parallel Trends
meaning the difference in these
intercepts stay the same over time we
can estimate this counterfactual it's
actually quite easy you just subtract
those differences from the after period
and then we can get an ID of the counter
factual and this can easily be estimated
using uh ordinary least squared or less
estimating estimation methods or if your
data is in a panel format panel OLS so
that's actually uh easy we can get some
outcomes here
however
I assumed I've made a very strong
assumption and that is this notion of
parallel trends
and what I want to you to think about
here is if you're in this quasi
experimental setting do these
assumptions that you're making do these
actually hold and basically with any
econometric model and what sources of
endogeneity may enter the model
well so think about for example omitted
variables that you forgot to include in
your model well the nice thing about the
difference in difference a model is that
individual effects so effects that
apply to certain cities so population
for example they cancel out in the model
time effects also cancel out in the
model so November and this Emirate
cancels out however interactive effects
they are a threat to our the validity of
our model so what do I mean with
interactive effects those are in just
the takeaway are typically weather and
certain holiday days
for example people order out food when
it's raining Raining is very local
happens to some cities and to some
cities it doesn't so in this interaction
of city and time we can have problems
some holiday days like Ramadan is also a
very important one for us because some
cities have a huge population that
celebrate Ramadan some cities don't
we see Ramadan has a huge effect on the
order volume well so if if you don't
account for this interaction then our
estimations can go horribly wrong
so these are violations of the parallel
Trends assumption that may enter the
model
so what can we do we have
from econometric research there are
several solutions to this think about
interactive fixed effect models it's
quite recent
however there's also more traditional
approach called the synthetic control
method which I'm not going to talk about
which also tries to solve solve this
problem yeah so these are other ways of
estimating this counterfactual
um by also addressing this problem of
the parallel Trends assumption that is
violated in our data
so let me also talk a little bit about
synthetic control so these are very
important models used within industry a
lot used to make a causal inference
and also remember that the validity of
these models it's very important and
we're making huge decisions based on
these outcomes marketing could be maybe
a couple of million euros for us so we
need to be very sure about these things
hence why hence why I'm addressing this
with synthetic control is basically what
we're doing is a smart form of matching
so remember we have cities in our
control and cities in our variants
um is that
well in a in a kind of optimal setting
we would have a pairing of a city uh
control City in a very City that are
very similar to each other but in
reality we never find a control in a
variant City that are exactly the same
so instead of this matching we do a
little bit of a smart matching we say
okay let a model find percentages of
cities in our control
so the example that I have here is held
hope and eindhover are in our control
and now we're gonna estimate that oh
five percent of the orders of einth over
95 of the orders of held up more or less
count up to the orders that we find in
best basically we're saying that this
kind of synthesized control serves as a
good Baseline for the order count we may
find the best
and this this works in practice and uh
basically what it's saying is a kind of
a similar seasonal effect than what we
may find in best
and it's easy to estimate we can just
use linear programming for this so you
could say yeah we're done
however
because we're using linear programming
we don't have confidence intervals we
don't have significance and a status if
your statistician you already are
getting nervous now because if we don't
have significance what does it mean can
we really trust the output
well our friends at Google
um they created a package which tries to
solve this problem it's called causal
impact
basically what they do is use Bayesian
structural time series for this matching
because it's Bayesian we get well we now
get credibility intervals not confidence
intervals technical thing but we get
some notion of uncertainty and we can
then basically do synthetic control with
confidence intervals
credibility intervals
again did we solve the problem well we
should still be very careful
why think about for example a city like
Amsterdam the biggest city in the
Netherlands can we and I suppose that's
in our variant set can we really find a
city like Amsterdam for which we can
find a good control
or or combination controls well
obviously not because no City will add
up to Amsterdam it's one of a kind
basically
so we still find that
some of the instruments that we're using
from for this matching are not uh valid
yeah so the outcomes that we we may get
and we have to be very careful
there can be a huge uh treatment effect
that we're estimating which is not
really there
so what to do
well if you've seen talks before about
synthetic control and difference in
difference
I think a lot of companies they try to
build their own synthetic control
framework they try to build very
complicated approaches
what we do we then just you take away is
we believe that we take multiple simple
models like difference in difference
like synthetic control
and we just get multiple outcomes
this is ambiguity this introduces a
notion of ambiguity
however this is not bad for us why
because this usually points to a
direction of a violation of one of our
assumptions
if a difference in difference gives us a
strange result hey the parallel trans
assumption might be violated
so this point usually points into a
direction which the underlying
assumptions are not met if they all
Point towards the same direction we're
happy and we found a robust treatment
effect so this is basically how we
approach this problem of causal
inference within jassi takeaway
now I'm gonna shift the my attention
from causal inference all the way to
uh to something completely different
which is scenario generation
and as I already said you can also
inference it's
extremely difficult why is it extremely
difficult because we're trying to
isolate a treatment effect from every
other confounder that might be present
in the data
well uh usually yeah the the point is
you never know whether you find found
the right right treatment effect because
we cannot directly observe it and we
have to estimate it
well if we drop the the the
uh the requirement of causality and we
just want to predict likely outcomes
we can use the power of predictive
modeling to our advantage
um so that's what I'm now going to talk
about and a recent uh
promising a technique in in forecasting
are the temporal Fusion Transformer
networks first I'm going to introduce
them a little bit and then I'm going to
tell you why I'm introducing those
so Temple Fusion Transformers are let's
say the uh the the birds models of
forecasting
so what what do I mean with that huh
bird models have been used in actual
language processing for a long time
to model long-term dependencies in your
input data so they're using natural
language processing so sentences
and with sentences it's extremely
important to have long-term dependencies
in your data because a word in the
beginning of a sentence might influence
a a word that comes at the end of a
sentence so in order to capture this
long-term dependencies they introduce
this notion of attention
what is intention basically it gives a
probability distribution over your
entire input sequence given a new
observation so it allows you to travel
back in time and basically find uh yeah
basically it's a method to to uh
uh quickly yeah to how to say that to
um yeah travel back in time so to say
easily
um well if you look at the old school
methods of forecasting oh I have this AR
in there Auto regressive models
statistics if you look at the more
modern forecasting techniques it's
profits the gradient boosting lstm and
cnns the more the Deep learning and
models for that
however most of these state-of-the-art
methods are still univariate and they
have one thing they want to predict
in our case we're interested in
multivariate forecasts why are we
interested in this and now I'm coming to
this point of scenario generation
we want to inject for example price
changes as a feature in our data set and
the nice thing about temporal Fusion
temporal Fusion Transformers is
we can inject into the model known
historic and future inputs
and a certain static covariates which
are which are the city parameters
so think about the known inputs that
we're now going to inject let's say
we're just going to inject price as a
known preview historic and future input
in our model
if our data and this is really important
if our data contains enough shocks so
think about switchbacks that happened in
the past
Etc we can really predict
a future possible
forecast using this price variable as a
kind of a a variable that we can vary
and what would the prediction be if we
change the price at this moment what
would it be which Enterprise at this
moment
and the nice thing about this approach
is that because it's using this notion
of attention we're also getting
long-term dependencies
I have typically with causal reasoning
you have an experiment or a quasi
experiment that runs for a small amount
of time
after a while uh you can imagine that
there's also long-term effects in the
data which you're not able to measure in
your experiment well with with these
kinds of approaches with attention you
get these long-term effects again
however and I A lot of people are
nervous now can we really draw any cause
or conclusions here obviously not this
is not also reasoning this is just
regenerating a scenario that we might
may find likely
so we should be very careful about
interpreting
these results
so
we can even go one step deeper
so suppose now
we know next month we're gonna expect an
order volume of a huge magnitude that
we've never seen before ever so using
this this model that I just described
um yeah so it's it's it's something new
right the the number of orders
can we already generate synthetic order
data on a minute to minute basis
using this number so we want to generate
orders synthetic orders such that we can
Benchmark our router algorithm
why is this important for us well this
router algorithm is basically the core
of our business basically this algorithm
matches drivers with orders
and we want to know that we have enough
drivers available and if you don't have
enough drivers maybe we need to get them
quickly
and other things like equipment we need
to know how many bicycles we need how
many people
um yeah so we need basically we need to
know whether Logistics is in order so
think about this we're generating first
predicting the number of orders that are
going to happen
then we're gonna uh generate synthetic
data
and then we're going to simulate this
data using some simulation tools and see
whether or not our system our router is
is robust against the number of orders
that we're now expecting
well there's a lot of research
surroundings that the data generation
for images and text
you've probably heard of GPT fee in
Dolly 2 recently
this picture on the right is also
generated using
Dolly too it's quite nice
now
how do we approach this problem
we are going to generate data using only
four variables time customer location
restaurant location food price so it's
actually a very low dimensional data
that we're that we want to generate
however don't be fooled this is not an
easy problem
because customer location and restaurant
location
are very tightly coupled they're very
highly correlated
as I already mentioned depending on your
location you only have access to some
restaurants
and all these variables are very tightly
coupled for example time and food price
people during lunch time usually order
lower foot counts for other prices
so there's a lot of correlations in this
data set that we need to address
uh another big challenge here is this
notion of sparsity
what are these restaurant location and
customer locations well if you think
about it they're actually categorical
variables and you cannot model it in a
different way but actually it's
categorical
well how many think about how many
addresses there are in a city like
Eindhoven well hundreds right maybe more
and some of these addresses might be
very rare but we do want to be able to
generate all of them so how to address
this this sparsity Challenge and that's
one of the things that we've been uh
working on
um
well
one of the things that we do to make the
problem tractable and it sounds quite
straightforward if I mention it here but
it's a very strong assumption that is
the Assumption of Independence
what do I mean with that I mean at every
order in the data is independent from
any other order in the data in reality
this is not the case because if I order
food I'm not going to order again
tonight I I don't do it twice
however because we have a huge number of
orders
basically we can make this assumption
right we
because we yeah we have so many options
that we can generate
and this allows us to make the problem
way more tractable because we can just
sample from a distribution
and by sampling from this distribution
and assuming Independence we can
actually generate a Time series
yeah I want to draw your attention to
this package called synthetic data fault
any company uh if you're interested in
this you can use this package it
contains a lot of models for synthetic
data generation so gaussian copulas more
from the statistics side
it's basically the idea here is that you
have a multivariate distribution you can
disentangle this distribution into
uniform marginal distributions and a
copula that describes the correlations
as basically it's statistical approach
we have the variational auto encoders as
also mentioned today already a couple of
times
from maxwelling
basically the idea is you have an auto
encoder which also serves which
generates also a nice latent space which
we can sample from so it allows
we can train outer code which also
allows sampling from the data
and we have the generative adversarial
networks and basically the idea is we
have an uh
proponent and an adversary basically
they're trying to uh well
yeah so we have a adversary which tries
to uh um predict whether or not a sample
is fake we have a proponent which tries
to synthesize this data basically
they're trained uh conjunctively and in
the end the adversary is not able to
distinguish anymore and we're able to
synthesize realistic data
well
and I already taught you a little bit
about uh some of the challenges sparsity
is for example challenge
however one of the challenges that we're
also working on is the problem of the
underlying distribution changing over
time
now think about it and the orders for
for next year well the order value would
be perhaps already be uh going up next
year due to inflation another thing
could be that some regions in the city
become more popular they had the order
distribution of the city may change over
time
can we capture that it's basically a
combination of synthetic data generation
and forecasting combined one of the
research questions that we're now
thinking about and trying to tackle
in any case uh it really allows us to
generate scenarios that we've never seen
before and that is really nice about
this and especially for companies in a
logistics space this is really a strong
a strong thing and I I truly believe
that synthetic data will be something of
the future that many companies will work
with
um yeah so this is the end of my
presentation
um so a lot of the things I've mentioned
is also uh
combination with the data science team
most of them are here and my here has
been working on synthetic data
generation Roberto the temple Fusion
forecasting so I'm not the only one here
um
and also I want to draw your attention
to some of the positions that are open
if you're interested in pricing we have
a principal data science position open
uh and also for the uh if you're
interested in engineering part we also
have a machine learning engineering
position open and the many interesting
and nice challenges uh awaits you
thanks for the very interesting talk Max
any question
from the audience yes please
uh thank you very much for the
interesting presentation
um so I was wondering why are you using
different indifference method for
causally inference I mean I myself I'm
aware of what I mean one method which is
potential outcome and yes I had the
impression that that could also fit into
this situation and why you're not using
that
um
basically yeah so potential the the
problem here is that we're
um uh
we need to compare cities with each
other right
and uh some cities uh a lot of cities
are different than other cities so
there's a huge number of individual
effects that we want to account for
right uh so this is why difference in
difference because we can basically get
rid of this individual effects that that
exists in the model but this is also
part of the potential outcome
framework right or am I mistaking here
how do you see how do you see yeah
building a potential outcome they would
have like let's say a control and
treatment group they try to uh correct
for the confounders that you mentioned
so that only there would be a difference
in that particular variable that you are
willing to gauge and in this case is a a
free let's say delivery so that means
you would have samples from a city which
is has bought or has not bought and and
also you would have sample within let's
say different I don't know holy months
or or other months or or also trying to
have a balanced group on both sides yeah
yeah we cannot randomize within the city
that that is the problem not within a
city we can only randomize over cities
that that is the challenge that we have
so
yeah
that is due to also legal issues that we
have
so yeah
yeah perhaps yeah
any other questions
thank you for your talk
um
so in the uh
synthetic method you were why are you
trying it on City level and not on a
lower level like a postal code said then
you probably can build up Amsterdam from
a comparable postal codes from all over
the country yeah now that's a very good
point uh very extremely good point and
this is also something uh which we're
doing actually I didn't want to go into
that much detail but indeed so the
decomposition is the key here yeah okay
so thank you
let's have one last question and no more
time
thank you for your presentation uh you
mentioned in the beginning that uh one
way to get more confidence is to you
just use more different models and if
they agree then awesome but what do you
do if they disagree yeah so you need to
have a lot of models in place and then
uh well if you have two models in place
and they disagree then there's no
Direction but if there's a couple of
models it gives you a general ID and
each of these models have a some
assumptions that they're making huh so
difference in difference uses this
parallel Trends assumption so that the
control uses the Assumption of you know
that you can that you can actually
synthesize a control based on the
combination of your controls
um so
if you have multiple methods and
basically you can choose a majority for
example then the minority is probably
the the the problematic case but you
also need to think about the the
assumptions that each of these models
are making I had to really assess what
is happening so it's yeah it requires
manual thinking
you cannot automate this
thank you yeah